[Applaudissements]
cet été j'étais un migrant enfin presque
le mot est peut-être un peu fort je vais
vous raconter ce qui m'est arrivé en
plein mois d'août
je me suis fait voler une sacoche avec
mes clés mes papiers et mon téléphone
portable ma famille en vacances à
l'autre bout de la france je suis devenu
un migrant dans ma propre ville avec
seulement 20 euros en poche
juste de quoi entrer chez moi à acheter
un ticket métro pour rentrer chez moi
moi qui suis habitué à tout faire et
qu'un smartphone je faisais un peu moins
le malin et là j'ai découvert mes
voisins formidables ils m'ont accueilli
ils m'ont aidé dans ce moment
désagréable
ils m'ont ouvert leur relation à mon
service j'ai surtout découvert que
j'avais des tas de choses à partager
avec eux des loisirs communs des
passions d enthousiasme qu'on aurait pu
partager
mais pourquoi ne laisse pas fait avant
que de temps perdu mais vous aussi avoué
le qui parmi vous n'a pas fait
connaissance de ses propres voisins dans
une situation de crise une panne une
urgence un cambriolage qui parmi vous
n'a pas été dans cette situation
paradoxale hyper connectés au monde
entier est totalement déconnecté de son
propre voisinage
d'ailleurs 70 % des citadins
reconnaissent avoir souffert de la
solitude et de l'isolément urbain j'en
suis vraiment convaincu
plus le monde devient digital plus le
retour au local est nécessaire
d'ailleurs vous allez rire même facebook
qui connectent chaque jour des centaines
de millions d'utilisateurs de manière
virtuelle est en train de reconstruire
son propre campus pour favoriser le
contact de ses collaborateurs dans la
vraie vie c'est dingue j'ai une bonne
nouvelle
pour échapper à ce monde digital
chaotique
la ville va devenir plus inclusive et
plus solidaire en effet la ville se
reconstruit autour de trois attentes
prioritaires des citadins aujourd'hui la
première c'est le tous ensemble
le tous ensemble c'est la consommation
collaborative
vous allez me dire c'est quoi la
consommation collaborative c'est
échanger des biens et des services
c'est partager des lieux de vie ou des
équipements c'est airbnb pour les
logements ces blablas car pour vos
voitures
moi ma préférée s'appelle et petite
cantine elle propose de se mettre à
table avec ses voisins en fait le moment
du repas devient un formidable arguments
pour échanger avec des habitants d'âge
est de provenance totalement différente
vous connaissez aussi beaucoup d'entre
vous le lui dans ma rue qui est une
belle initiative qui réinvente et
services de proximité à paris de ce
partage n'est une convivialité qui est
le bénéfice qui revient régulièrement
chez les adeptes de ceux de ce type de
consommation colorado collaborative
c'est moins cher et c'est vraiment cool
la deuxième attentes de nos citoyens
d'aujourd'hui
ces deux un besoin de ré enchantement ré
enchanter son quotidien c'est prendre du
recul par rapport à ce quotidien c'est
sortir du cadre
la nature en ville s'inscrit tout à fait
dans cette attente c'est remettre du
végétal dans cette ville très minéral
très dur très pollué les premiers toit
végétalisé sont apparus dès 2008
et c'est désormais 30 hectares de
d'agriculture urbaine que la ville de
paris veut développer d'ici 2020 la
troisième attentes et elle est
importante c'est créer du lien pour se
développer
là c'est tout ce qui a permis de
développer ces tirs lieu il y en a plus
d'un millier en france
ils ont été multipliés par trois ces
quelques années alors c'est d'abord les
espaces de coworking com - work ou next
door qui accueille
des auto entrepreneurs des freelances
des consultants mais également des start
up qui viennent s'y installer pour
prendre leur envol
tous y viennent pour créer des liens
avec d'autres entrepreneurs pour sortir
de leur isolement et pour profiter d'une
certaine sérendipité qui a occasionné
par ces rencontres alors c'est quoi la
sérendipité sait rebondir sur des
concours de circonstances c'est grâce à
ces roms dépité qu'on a fait en deux
innovations majeures dans notre vie le
post it et le viagra
alors c'est ces espaces de coworking ont
continué à se développer très rapidement
pour accompagner la croissance des
actifs non salariés qui représenteront
dès 2020 plus 25% de la population après
le coworking le coding apportera aux
jeunes urbains des appartements optimisé
au sein de communautés très actifs dans
des lieux de destination porteur de
valeurs fortes
c'est une formidable alternative à la
fois aux marchands de sommeil et au
colloque d'étudiants alors tout tout
tout ce ce phénomène s'accélère
on le sent bien on sent bien qu'on passe
de l'économie du bien à l'économie du
lien comment ces trois attentes vont l
impact et les aménagements urbains de
demain
moi j'y vas quatre impacts le premier
impact c'est la mixité des usages la
mixité des usages ça veut dire quoi sert
créer des quartiers très mixte à la fois
où il ya du bureau mais également du
logement des commerces de proximité des
services du coordinateur des jeunes
7 c'est la fin des cités dortoirs c'est
la fin des quartiers d'affaires
totalement déséquilibrée on réinvente en
fait les faubourgs les quartiers euros-
magnan de paris que nous aimons tous
cette mixité des usages favorise la
mixité sociale c'est à dire le partage
entre des générations et des groupes
sociaux différents
c'est le deuxième impact le troisième
impact c'est la mutabilité des bâtiments
comment faire pour que des bâtiments de
bureaux inoccupés soit transformé en
logements ou des parkings silos soit
transformé en logements
rien qu'à paris c'est 2,5 millions
deux mètres carrés de parking silo
inoccupés qui pourraient être
transformés en vingt-cinq mille
logements de 100 mètres carrés
c'est considérable et enfin le quatrième
impact c'est l'émergence de plateformes
économique local ça veut dire quoi
dans tous les projets du grand paris
chaque quartier aura une identité forte
qui va lui donner une dynamique locale
il viendra alors un lieu de destination
pour l'ensemble des riverains que ce
soit les habitants les salariés ou les
visiteurs on réinvente en fait des
places du village
à l'intérieur de ces villes je vous le
promets vous allez aimer cette ville qui
arrive parce qu'elle vous permettra de
vous développer faites moi confiance
quand on a passé comme moi vingt ans de
sa vie à la courneuve dans cet
environnement là on a une sacrée envie
de s'en sortir est d'apporter un autre
univers dans les banlieues comme ce
quartier qu'on est en train de
construire à nanterre vous aussi vous
allez à deux juges je suis devenu un
activiste de la ville parce que je crois
qu'elle peut être désirable
vous aussi vous allez désirer cette
ville parce qu'à vous permettra de
retrouver un ancrage local pour vous
sortir de l'isolément du digital vous
aussi vous allez désirer cette ville car
elle permettra d'être le lieu de vos
rencontres et de vos aventures urbaines
humaines vous aussi vous allez désiré
votre cette ville parce qu'elle vous
permettra de vous épanouir plus
facilement à la fois dans votre travail
et dans vos loisirs
j'espère qu'on s'entend de cette salle
comme moi vous vous direz elle est pas
belle la ville
[Applaudissements]